sorry dass ich aussehe wie Idiot
ist aber eigentlich eh nichts Neues
passt aber auch vielleicht ganz gut zum
heutigen Video denn ich reagiere mal
wieder auf hilf mir Psycho Lehrer Harry
und ich habe ehrlich gesagt mal wieder
absolut gar keine Erwartungen
was denkt der denn das hat irgendwie
eine Sportklasse da ist alter das ist
nicht die
Bundesstraße
amerikanischer Bundeswehr
[Musik]
die Klasse ist aber auch richtig am
Arsch genauso stellt man sich die Klasse
vor die man überhaupt nicht unterrichten
will
meistens ist das die B
schreibt mal unten in die Kommentare in
welcher Klasse ihr wart laupe mein Name
euch Mathe beizubringen damit ihr euren
Abschluss gekriegt habe
ey sorry egal was der Lehrer machen wird
ich werde vollstes Verständnis haben der
hier vorne hat seine Chips ausgepackt
sie chillt ihr mit komplettmenü einfach
am rumgammeln und sie bedient sich jetzt
auch noch bei den Chips
als erstes
Sachen weg Essen
und beschwert sich jetzt auch noch
danach Alter kommt die klar er hat schon
wieder das nächste ist losgefahren
egal hallo
nach dem Unterricht kriegt ihr es wieder
sehr gut
klar Bro alles klar Alter was ist das
denn der ist kein bisschen cool ist ein
riesen Arschloch mein Handy weggenommen
nicht mal mein Vater macht ist ja sollte
er vielleicht aber mal
die Sache ist ich würde mir bei ihr als
beispielsweise denken sie ist echt ein
hübsches Mädchen aber mit diesem
übermäßigen schminken und dieser Style
das assoziiert einfach in Kombination
mit der redeart ein Bobby schlauer
dieser Satz gerade
assoziiert in Kombination mit der
redeart
warum Mario Youtube bitte
egal
[Musik]
also erstmal ganz kurz
dass er jetzt den Style von seinen
Schülern kritisiert geht natürlich gar
nicht auf der anderen Seite sollte die
SchülerInnen aber auch nicht Kontern mit
nur weil sie so schäbig aussehen und er
kommt dann halt an mit dem schweigefuchs
den man aber glaube ich gar nicht mehr
machen darf
du bist ruhig nur zuhören ich rede okay
okay
[Musik]
also es war schon hier im Video zensiert
aber hat er die gerade beleidigt
also habe ich auch nicht verstanden
diese Poster die hat sich doch nie
irgendwie Idiot angeguckt geschrieben
was immer irgendwann werdet
wie bitte
der beleidigt ja nur also ich habe keine
Ahnung was er sagt weil es wie gesagt
doch jetzt zensiert ist aber wenn die
das schon Piepen müssen hat er
anscheinend wiederum beleidigt
Zuhälter
du hast wahrscheinlich schon danke
dass wir ein Loser im Raum haben
es reicht ja dass wir einen Loser im
Raum haben wir denn jetzt noch einen
zweiten
dicker was diese Mädels dafür Sprüche
raushauen ne wie heißt du ja Cindy wer
besser für dich Cindy candy
kannst du die Nachfolge werden von Cindy
aus Marzahn Masse
aus Kalk nein nein nein
Kalk ist in Köln als wenn das jetzt
wieder in Köln spielt
dann können Sie selber schreiben neue
Regel jeder bringt Sportsachen mit und
sollte irgendeiner von euch die Matte
Unterricht hier irgendwann nur Schwänzen
oder keinen Bock haben irgendwie sich
daneben 6
und wo wir jetzt die Sportsachen kann
Lehrer von der Stange aber die Kids sind
eben auch keine Kids von der Stange und
der Lehrer hat möglicherweise kapiert
dass es ohne Disziplin nicht geht und
vor allen Dingen was wirkt es die
kriegen wir was anderes serviert als die
übliche Kost in der Schule ja das ist
auch gut
wenn ihr da immer so Firlefanz Lehrer
haben die da nicht gegen ankommen und so
dann muss halt mal so mit jemand kommen
so Candy und ihre Mitschüler hassen den
Lehrer und seine Methoden jetzt schon
doch das ist erst der Anfang okay
Schafskopf
also das ist ein Lehrer durchgreifen
muss manchmal wenn so eine Schulklasse
Auftritt okay aber Bro diese Beleidigung
ja okay es ist halt eh alles nur
gespielt ne wahrscheinlich wird am Ende
die Quintessenz sein oh die Schüler
Werken dass sie echt gut lernen
mittlerweile und haben Lust auf die
Schule und schreiben jetzt viel bessere
Noten hilf mir
macht die Tür zu mach die Tür zu machen
solche Schuhe an
die denken auch irgendwie fashion dicker
das ist thematisch Stunde
[Musik]
der sammelt das Essen von den Schülern
ein und ist das einfach auf und wenn die
sagen das ist meins dann sagt er das ist
ihm scheißegal ist vielleicht solltest
mal ein bisschen weniger von diesen
Schokoriegeln jetzt ein bisschen was
gesünderes
Weg
[Musik]
okay das ist dann wiederum in Ordnung
finde ich dieses nimm mal die Füße
runter weil es ist logisch dass man
seine Füße nicht da drauf macht aber ein
klassischer lehrersprache wird es zu
Hause auch so machen ja
was für eine dumme Aussage immer von
Lehrern sagst du einfach ja oder ist das
komplette Argument zerstört gestern
gesagt Sportsachen mitbringen hast du
die dabei
zieh die Sportsachen an fünf Runden
Platz
[Musik]
oh mein Gott mich erinnert das gerade
ein bisschen anders minecraft-projekt
mit Sandra wo ich immer 20 Liegestütze
machen muss wenn Sandra stirbt
die Ruhe bleibt
alle raus für eure Sportsachen an du
hast es gehört
dann Hörzu halt dein Mund
also oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott jetzt müssen alle fünf
Runden und Platz laufen kurz darauf
terrorlehrer Harry fackelt nicht lange
und sorgt dafür dass seine Schüler
Disziplin lernen oh mein Gott
ich bin raus was ist das für eine Hilfe
nicht mal bei der Hälfte und es gibt
noch einen zweiten Part ey ohne mich
[Musik]